i want to thank a few people who have
joined us today you'll hear from some of
them first
commissioner michael naft from clark
county uh he's been a tireless advocate
for
the project and for the parking and
transportation plan these
this is his district these are his
constituents we've had
um public forums we've had a lot of
meetings with the business owners to
find out what they wanted and make sure
we addressed
their concerns and michael's being the
impetus behind that so thank you you'll
hear from him in a second
i'd also like to welcome mj maynard ceo
of rtc
you'll hear for some of their plans in
terms of the transportation of getting
people
to this location as well as chuck
bolling president and ceo of mandalay
bay
and luxor one of our partners mgm and
our next door neighbor chuck's been a
big supporter
from day one and been a great friend of
the raiders
i'd also like to recognize captain
roxanne burke from las vegas metro she's
with us today
thank you very much for being here
metro's been a huge part of everything
we've been doing in the stadium
transportation security
um and we're excited that we're going to
open the stadium to fans and
and have them be a presence and help
provide a safe secure environment for
our fans
lastly i'd like to acknowledge patrick
garvey you're starting to see more pat g
shirts all around town and
he's built a parking empire here he came
on board
with mgm and with t-mobile and developed
the very successful parking plan for the
vegas golden knights
that everybody around town has has
experienced the last three years and
his experience and what he's brought to
this project for us has been invaluable
so thanks for being on board
uh before i i explain a little bit more
about the problem i would like to call
commissioner nafta i know he has a few
remarks
michael
well good morning thank you mark as mark
said it was really important to me that
our local community along with visitors
to the area
have a clear and full understanding of
what the transportation plan will look
like
as we get ready to fill allegiant
stadium with fans
i appreciate mark's collaborative
approach and the raiders organization
that they've taken over these last three
three years
it's been incredible they've really
taken to heart the needs of
the impacted businesses in the area the
needs of the property owners
and the needs of those who live in my
district and in the surrounding area
the transportation plan will be laid out
that will be laid out today offers
something for all users and i thank mj
and the rtc
uh for really being part of finding
solutions for all of our users in this
community and for everybody to enjoy
this stadium
it's also important to acknowledge the
uniqueness of this stadium
its proximity to the greatest
entertainment district on the planet the
las vegas strip
and what that means for visitors and for
our economy here in southern nevada
like so many in our community this is a
conversation that
i'd hope we've been having a year ago
being able to come out and make this
announcement today
but i could not be happier that we're
here at this moment with a fully
reopened clark county and the most
incredible stadium
to lead the way in this recovery so
thank you so much and go raiders
[Applause]
thank you commissioner i appreciate
appreciate the kind words and and again
thanks for
for the support over the years as
commissioner nafta mentioned
when we were looking at locations for
the stadium going back five years we
looked all over the valley and when this
piece of property
became available we really couldn't
believe it because it it its proximity
to this strip
as along with being adjacent to the
strip was just so valuable
and you start talking about all the the
reasons that it's valued when you come
back to the ingress egress and parking
and transportation plan
so we anticipate and we've surveyed our
fans
and we anticipate having a good chunk of
the fan base
going down starting their day on the
strip and then coming to the game and
then ending their day on the strip
and so what we've worked on is the
bridge you see behind us the hacienda
bridge
will be closed to vehicular traffic and
will become part of the stadium walk in
the stadium experience
you'll hear from chuck bowling later on
about some of the events they have
planned down at their properties
we anticipate a lot of the resort
corridor holding events for fans coming
to the games
they'll make their way down here they'll
walk across the bridge with fellow fans
and make their way into the stadium so
any way you come down to the strip
whether it be by uber by other ride
share partners
whether you drive and park there whether
you get dropped off there you're going
to have this fan experience of coming
across the bridge
with fellow raider fans if you are on
the strip let's talk a little bit about
rtc
and the popular double decker deuce bus
it runs 24 7
it has a stop at mandalay bay and mj
maynard is going to tell us a little bit
more about that
it's like he's on our team he knows all
about our service
so um on behalf of the regional
transportation commission
i am so happy to be here today i think
like many southern nevadans
we have been waiting uh for the
opportunity to root on
our beloved football team the las vegas
raiders in person
this year in alleged stadium and is
right our
double deck buster's very popular they
run uh
24 7 365.
the deuce itself has 57 bus stops
that start in the north in downtown las
vegas
run through las vegas boulevard to the
south and as mark mentioned because the
hudson
bridge will be closed to particular
traffic uh if you are anywhere on the
strip
again those 57 stops whether your
favorite casino bar restaurant
you can hop on a deuce bus and you can
take it to the stop in front of mandalay
bay and it's
literally a stone's throw from the
hospital bridge so very convenient
we anticipate the bus running every 15
minutes or less
if we find that there is a lot of demand
a lot of customers
want to experience the game day by bus
to get to the bridge to walk to legion
stadium
we can scale up so if it's really busy
we'll add more deuce buses in to ensure
that that game day experience is a good
one
but we're also not just about buses at
the rtc we are also about
uh roads and cars because we are the
regional traffic manager for the
for the eight uh for the region so we're
going to be working closely with metro
with the raiders team we will have a
presence here at legion stadium on site
in their traffic control room
to ensure that we help with the ingress
and regress we'll be able to adjust
traffic signals again
in conjunction with metro in real time
to ensure that there's a flow traffic
that it ensures that even after the game
it's a great
game day experience so i want to thank
mark for the opportunity to be here
today
and absolutely go raiders
thanks mj uh i want to give you a couple
of facts
uh all this information will be on our
website so you don't necessarily need to
take notes
and you see the maps behind us that have
a lot of the information as well
for uber and rideshare you see those
denoted in blue on the map
i want to explain that this is an
iterative process so while you see the
information that's present today
that's what's official as of june 3rd
but we're constantly working with
business owners we have a bunch of
negotiations going on
with additional properties and as we
gain more we'll add that information
to the website and communicate that to
our fans and those that are coming to
our games and to other events at
legion stadium so we have ride share
options both on
the east south and northwest sides of
the stadium i want to thank the governor
for the legislation he passed last week
to allow rideshare to to return to its
pre-pandemic levels that's obviously
very helpful for the strip corridor
and will be for our games as well we
have a dedicated space west of the
stadium available for taxis
shuttles general drop off and pick up
before and after the games
and the majority of these lots will all
have shuttles golf carts available for
ada use
and to to get patrons from the stadium
to their lots and back and forth
there's no shortage of parking options
available
the nfl when they send out parking
service they usually ask for how many
spaces you have within a mile radius of
the stadium
and while obviously a mile is too long
for some patrons to walk most people
in most nfl markets are willing to walk
that far to come to the games again
we'll have shuttles for those that can't
make the walk but within a mile of this
stadium are 35
000 parking spots when we surveyed our
fans like i mentioned earlier we found
that we needed about twelve thousand so
we do feel that we have over supply but
until we actually play games until we
actually have concerts until we have all
the events that are planned for legion
stadium
we don't know so we wanted to over
commit and then we'll figure things out
along with all of our partners that are
here today and some that aren't here
today
and we'll make the necessary changes
we'll listen to our fans we'll get their
feedback
and we'll understand what's working and
what's not uh we were always doing that
at previous locations and we'll do that
here
we have 13 000 spots that are under our
complete control meaning we either own
them
either on-site here at lots that we've
invested money and purchased
or that we have long-term leases with
the property owners some of them have
tailgating options
some of them don't you'll get that
information in a second there's another
22 000 spots located on the resort
corridor and in other businesses around
this area some of which have said
we're going to handle parking ourselves
some of which we're going to control
so again we have 35 000 spots and it's a
distributed parking plan meaning it's
not all in one
single spot and what we've found in
other locations at other stadiums both
in rural areas and in urban areas the
more distributed you can get the better
it is for both ingress and egress and
the entire experience
you see on the maps behind me the
parking fees they range from forty
dollars to one hundred dollars
in the raider controlled lots and they
lead in stadium controlled lots
they average about seventy five dollars
that's comparable with nfl stadiums
around the league
we did survey like i said we did survey
our fans um
i think they're going to be surprised at
how affordable the parking is they were
willing to pay substantially more
certainly to park closer and adjacent to
the stadium we do encourage those
that are going to drive and park and and
come to the stadium
and be a part of that tailgating
experience to come early the first few
games
we know it's going to be a challenging
process we're not naive to that people
are going to come here
we're going to give them a design of of
where they should go but as we like to
say water seeks its own level and if
you're driving on a path and an app
or some instruction tells you where to
go and there's a
parking lot in front of you you're going
to say i know a better route and so
we're going to be
studying that we're going to be prepared
for that we've talked with metro about
that and
pat g in terms of studying the trends
and and
visualizing it from above and seeing
where the bottlenecks actually occur
we're going to start selling season-long
passes
in the next couple of weeks we're going
to email and start with
our locals so local psl holders will get
first crack along with club seat buyers
and then we'll move on to psl holders in
other markets
so that's the process uh our our service
team is going to start reaching out
to their accounts shortly and start
making appointments people make a
decision whether they want to purchase
a season-long pass if they decline
they'll be given information on single
event passes if you're not planning on
coming to all 10 games
perhaps you'll only buy on the single
game market so when you get to the
single game market
most of those will be available on the
spot hero app most people are familiar
with that
they've used it for other games they've
used it for other venues that's where
those will be
we do encourage again if you're going to
want to tailgate
make sure that the lot that you purchase
it allows tailgating the ones you're
sitting on right now the ones we own
all out tailgating that's about 6500
spots that we have control that we can
put tailgating in
when we were in oakland we had about 9
000 total spots we had about 2500 active
tailgates going on in any particular
game
so we feel again that we have more than
enough supply here for the demand that
we've seen in the past as well as the
demand that the surveys showed
so we've got 6 500 spots available for
tailgating
make sure if you purchase it that you
know that you can tailgate on that lot
otherwise you'll show up we don't want
you to be disappointed on game day
we've spent about 50 million dollars
acquiring property
committing to leases we add some
additional money that we've put into the
actual parking lots but we've made a
very significant financial
uh contribution to make sure that we
have enough capacity we have enough
parking
so in addition our lots and the stadium
controlled lots we know that the resort
corridor
is going to offer the best entertainment
in the world and they're going to look
to make sure that on our game days and
on other event days there are activities
for
people that are on the strip before and
after the games so i'm going to
invite chuck bolling to come up and and
explain what they have
ready for our fans at mandalay bay and
luxor chuck
well good morning and and and thank you
so much for inviting me here today
uh i want to start by congratulating
mark and the entire raiders organization
on this gorgeous stadium that's behind
me here today in this world-class
franchise that you have brought to las
vegas
you've already contributed so much to
the community i just want to take the
opportunity to say thank you for
spending the time giving back especially
over this last year
and know this foundation you've created
will be felt
for years to come now to say that we're
all excited about the 2021 football
season allegiant stadium might be the
biggest understatement over the
last year the return of fans to
large-scale sports and entertainment
represents the biggest milestone in our
city's recovery
it's one of the final pieces of the
puzzle of that recovery
bottom line we can't wait now one thing
i know is that mr davis and mr biden
have made a commitment to excitement and
excellence on the field
all the way to a world championship uh
they have also that will only be topped
by the excitement
that they will create from the time the
fans and the moment they arrive at
allegiant stadium
but see that's where the comparison to
any other city
in america stops and that's where las
vegas raises the bar
see we are here to create weekends of
memories
not just what happens over four hours
and i was at a press conference with
mark about a year ago
and said to people then and i will tell
you now i'm the luckiest person live
every day i drive by this incredible
stadium
only look right next door and see my
home of manley bay
and luxor see it's our job now to create
the energy from the moment visiting fans
arrive in the city
or when local fans wake up in the
morning for many that electric moment
will begin when they arrive
at these properties to enjoy the
credible festivities
we are planning all weekend long to
eventually walk
walk across the hacienda bridge to the
stadium i think we're starting
traditions that will be shared
for generations and that's why last
month we announced
mgm resort stadium walk experience and
have seen
tremendous response from football fans
nationwide the one of a kind only in las
vegas experience will offer the energy
and interactive environment of a
tailgate party
right on the strip and the convenience
of being right next door to the stadium
manalei bay and luxor will be at the
center of the action and the beer garden
will offer the ultimate outdoor day
getaway
we've created a number of special room
and food and beverage
packages multiple on property
activations
and a variety of sports related
festivities live entertainment options
to be enjoyed throughout the season now
manali bay
delano luxor will offer convenient valet
and sell parking for local and out of
town fans
event day parking passes will vary by
property
vip like mark has mentioned we'll also
have vip single game
and season-long parking passes will also
be valid at delano
now we strongly encourage guests to take
advantage of a prepaid
parking through the park mobile app many
people have already uh
logged onto that app for t-mobile arena
to make the overall experience both
convenient and seamless
and las vegas is the leader bringing
large groups together
safely as we collaborate with the
raiders and the legion
stadium on events for the latter part of
2021 and beyond
security and safety of our guests it
remains our top priority
so mark i want to take the opportunity
to say thank you for this opportunity
and together i know we're going to
create memories and traditions for
decades to come
wishing you an incredibly successful
season and
go raiders
thank you chuck uh in closing
i want to thank a few people we
appreciate the support
and the partnership of rtc clark county
las vegas metro the nevada highway
patrol ndot
our partners on the strip mgm uh our
rideshare partner uber
i want to thank everyone at the clark
county staff that's helped us nancy's
been a big help nancy amandson
and a number of folks at clark county
have been supportive and helpful for
four or five years running and we hope
that the plan today
gives you the basic facts you need we're
here to answer additional questions
as chuck mentioned we can't wait to open
the stadium up to fans we've had
some psl open houses the last couple
weeks we had one last night
and so fans are getting their first
chance if they haven't been in the
building for some other event or for a
tour to see their seat
and just to see people's faces when they
walk in there's a real sense of pride
this is a stadium that was built
in a public private partnership it was
built it's part of this community
uh we're humbled by it and we're proud
that
it it was built on time on budget and
it's going to be part of the resurgence
of las vegas but to see the fans come in
there and see what
what was built and see what they now
have in their hometown it's
um it's a really nice moment and when
there's 65 000 people in there for
concerts
and for games it's going to be pretty
electric so we thank you for being here
this morning all of us are going to
stick around if you have any questions
we're happy to answer them